boom we're doing it it's happening we're
going live let me just do a little
Instagram blast real quick so everybody
knows we're doing this guy's thank you
for joining for the the 4th Punisher VFX
livestream we're doing a big we're gonna
make something cool today we're gonna
figure out exactly what we're doing in a
second here
once I blast it out on Instagram all
right
we are live welcome welcome everybody
it's time it's time to do it it's time
all right you know I should have handle
all this stuff beforehand right I should
have I cheated out beforehand I am I've
the effects dream let's go all right
you know this is just this is just
taking a minute here let's just hop in
alright guys so we're doing it we're
gonna figure out what we want to do so
last week I made an image that you guys
had probably already seen and it is
let's see let's see
it's of this like tree the Zen garden
inside of this concrete little area you
know very modern very sleek right and I
was inspired by a little short film that
my buddy Ethan showed me and it's called
the third and the seventh and I'll show
you guys what that is right now so the
third and the seventh is an amazing
amazing little short film here look at
this this is so nice so basically this
guy I think he uses 3ds Max and he just
spent like who knows how long probably a
good while this this short is like yeah
nearly 13 minutes long and he created
all these amazing scenes and shot it in
a way that is very like it's very filmic
you know he's actually got the film
fades going and the stuff looks near
photo real the his lighting is
incredible
oh man little my little cat Gilbert he's
crawling all over the keyboard here hey
bud so yeah this guy is like going to
town here with these lens flares and
he's got some film grain goin
he's got the film fade going which is
different from a normal fade a film fade
is when basically the shadows dip out
first and the mid-tones and highlights
of the last things to leave and same for
when you fade in the first thing you'll
see is highlights
and then mid-tones and shadows and you
might see it here you might do a little
thing here but yeah you see that right
here and look at the fade in if there
yeah see how you get the highlights
first and then everything else kind of
rolls in
so his cinematography throughout all of
this is just in credible I'll skip
around to the middle see see this look
this like concrete interior look it's
kind of what I was going for with the
tree thing so this was the inspiration
right this is so beautiful if you guys
have a chance to look up the 3rd and the
7th and watch this whole thing it's
beautiful so we got the discord going if
you guys hadn't signed up for the
discord yet please do that it's a place
where all of us can get together and you
know communicate and chat about 3d stuff
visual effects anything that you guys
want to learn we can talk about it there
and I'll do it here I've heard you guys
I know that you want substance designer
tutorials I know that you want like how
to incorporate like your 3d objects into
your live-action plates that you've shot
right so we'll definitely do those today
however I'm going to do this you know
Zen garden concrete thing we'll do
another one of those because I really
want to get that down but yeah I got the
discord link down below in the
description of this video I also have a
playlist of all the ambient music and
chill music that I eat that I listen to
when I do V effects and honestly when
I'm just doing anything because it's
half the music I listen to anyway but uh
yeah that playlist that Spotify playlist
is in the description for this stream
right now so you guys can go go there
turn it on I can't play it because if I
want to monetize these things I can't
have music going on these streams but go
there yourself turn on just shuffle play
all those jams there and I'll be adding
more to that playlist as we go and as I
discover more cool ambient music but
let's see how are you guys doing
everyone is chillin everyone says hello
to Gilbert he appreciates you he's down
there
he knocked my pen tablet down onto the
ground um hello hello kouha Kuya asks
why I have two versions of After Effects
that's because one version runs a plugin
called real real steady and it's like a
it's like a you know camera
stabilization plug-in that only runs for
like the oldest version of After Effects
so that's why I have to after fixed um
let's see it was the thing around my
neck these are bone phones
these are awesome they're like bone
conduction headphones that vibrate you
don't put them in your ear you put them
you know kind of right right in this
area here and it you know vibrates a
little bit and yeah you can listen to
some cool music and I'll actually I
think I'll put on that Spotify playlist
all right I'm in sweet yeah cool thing
about these is you can hear obviously
cuz your ears aren't plugged and you
know can run with these you can hike
with these you know they're the best I
love them so much Michael asks is it
good to get started into the 3d world
with blender or should I get something
else dude 100% blender is the best I
personally have never used it but it's
the best because it's free and I've seen
what you can do with blender and my
goodness it's crazy
just look up Ian's Hubert or Peter
France and these guys and also blender
guru these guys are the best
they are like prodigies when it comes to
blender so don't be discouraged just
because it's a free it's a free program
doesn't mean it's no good guys
milene I or Melanie I don't have the
almonds today you know it's never too
late they're just over there but I do
have my car
koffie so my decaf coffee so I'll be
good to go what else guys what else what
else you got going on is everybody doing
VFX during the week you guys working on
your craft during the week spending time
working on your growing your value
working on yourself what do we got going
on here muskrat muskrat Mike we got we
got uh what do we have going on here
actually let me open up my old project
file for this tree we're gonna make a
cool Zen garden deal
let's do open recent yeah so once the
scene loads
I will render it and you guys I'll give
you guys a quick overview of this like
Zen interior Zen garden that I did last
week break it down really quick it's
very simple actually most of the time
went into figuring out my composition
and building the interior space just
because I didn't really know what I
wanted to do I was searching and that'll
kind of be a similar situation here I
have an idea you know we want to do an
interior Zen space do I think I'm better
than Ren and VFX I know Ren Ren is
probably the best compositor I know he's
always teaching me different tips and
tricks on how to better composite my 3d
or even 2d stuff into my footage Ren is
incredible he's the one who got me into
octane and octane is what you're seeing
here this like sort of viewing window so
Ren got me into octane ran was the
texture master
he's been recently doing a lot of his
like the effects VFX artist explains the
size of the universe or the scale of the
universe or you know like how big our
atoms are how smaller atoms you know
he's doing these kind of videos he's
been spending putting more of his time
points into that and recently he's been
building a drone that he's attached a
like a nerf gun to base
quickly to fire Nerf darts it's it's
crazy that episode is coming out on
corridor crew in the next couple weeks
all right guys what is my special
specialty in 3d or modeling or VFX
um I really really love texturing it's
just very very fun for me
I love modeling as well and I do love
compositing I really love the whole
process and that's the best part about
working at corridor as I get to do
everything in the process I don't I
wouldn't want to just do one thing I
like everything and because I'll get
bored doing one thing forever I have to
mix it up I need contrast in life um I
think which is why I can be music so
much because the day-to-day is just like
non-stop you know and the ambi music is
a good chance to chill out Trevor I'm
running a gtx 1070 just one of them i
would like to upgrade very soon and get
a second 1080 perhaps it's probably
pretty cheap at this point right you can
run two of them but let's take a look at
the scene this viewing window let's just
uh let's see here let's bring our scene
down to like something real small and
you guys can get an idea here of like
what this is you saw the picture right
so i can pause the viewer lets go in
here and hop out of camera view and this
is the setup for the scene so i have
like a roof here you know if we go into
this building
come on there we go so you got your tree
this is I'm using a plug-in called
Forester and it's really cool because
you can swap these trees out for
basically any tree you want right so you
can switch it out for a giant beech tree
like this which could be cool or a
Barbary tree which looks pretty Japanese
actually I might might do that for this
for today's image we got palm trees you
know that's just up and out of there and
for the lighting setup you guys can see
down here I have a couple like holes in
the roof to allow some natural light
into so I have these like little these
slits right here where light pours down
into the room from and I'm using a
sunlight an octane daylight system and
that's bringing your Sun down into here
I also have an HDRI image that is
projected around the whole scene that
determines the color color of the light
and the shape of the light and
everything a little bit I don't give you
guys some examples on what that the
difference between the that and sunlight
is and then I have a right here in area
light which is basically just like a
giant light panel that is boosting a
little bit of this height of the lights
here down onto this tree and it took me
man it took me almost like something so
long just to shape the light in this
that was the the biggest part was
getting the lighting right so it's a
constant play between your you know
modeling this this room here because the
shape of the room determines the best
camera angle you'd want and the camera
angle determines the camera angle I
guess the lighting too right the
lighting determines the camera angle a
little bit as well so I was trying to
make it you know work and make it
aesthetic
but I think at the end of the day the
biggest thing I didn't like about this
image was it felt a little empty on this
right side here and it just felt the
framing I'm a big fan of symmetry and
center frame stuff so maybe today we'll
do more of a symmetrical rendering so
God rays god rays are basically
volumetric light and you could do that
let's say make a new scene here we'll
render this to our to our viewer down
here right so if you add a sunlight like
we just did in cinema or an octane you
have this line and the line is the
direction of your Sun so if I rotate
this down straight down that's gonna be
like 12 noon
pointed right down at that thing and
there's actually a checkbox
oh oh and real quick so you see how it
looks all chunky right here that's
because we need to up these segments for
the sphere now it's looking nice but
let's do um let's hide the daylight I'll
show you guys with this HDR is you see
in the picture viewer it's just like
this scene around your geometry it's
lighting your scene based off of an HDR
eye picture so if we were to bring the
exposure down in the camera you could
see how those highlights there's
actually detail on the highlights back
here right so an HDR I picture is made
up of five or six different pictures at
varying exposures so you have a lot of
light detail in your scene and then you
combine that with the sunlight and you
see how that HDR I went away now
basically what you can do is check the
let's see
and the sunlight tab you can scroll down
and check the sky texture and then now
you have both you have the sunlight and
the hgri working together and that is
what I did for the Zen garden scene
right here once that guy's bareback
alright so let's see let's start a new
scene and build out our room what is the
room gonna look like now it's easy to do
this when you have reference a lot more
difficult when you don't have reference
so let's go to good old Google and look
up interior zen gardens
so something like this is pretty sweet
there's a lot of cool stuff in here
very peaceful looking yeah this kind of
stuff is awesome
it's very bright something like this
it's kind of like an architectural
rendering I this this might be a render
who knows this is super cool I like this
a lot
mmm I'll save this guy
this is pretty sweet too very simple
this is a good one I'll save that oh
this is nice
this is very very nice so yeah basically
you just want to find references that
you guys oh wow that is that is amazing
I wish my house looked like this one day
basically you want to find references so
that it's easier to get to your final
image it's a lot more difficult when
you're just going off the top of the
head it's gonna take a lot longer Oh
what this is crazy
hmm okay so it'd be really cool to do
something with water as well like this
is super cool that looks absolutely
beautiful
let's see what do you guys you guys
think
so yeah I'm going for a modern style in
a minimalist style I like simplicity
definitely a lot of that but it's also
cool to have something like there's this
guy Cornelius Dom Rick and I talked
about him on the last stream but
basically he has something oh my
goodness he has some incredible renders
this one here certainly is not simple
but you know you can you can tell that
like all the detail that went into this
totally makes up the image and
simplicity is not something he was going
for with this one
a lot of work went into this image and
it really really pays off it looks
incredible the detail on this is insane
there's like dirt and rocks above the
the doorframe here all these different
posters that are custom made you know he
has daylight and warm light mixing
together to give a really really cool
look he's got a lot a lot of Easter eggs
hidden in here too and he actually on
his website gives away some of these
models so yeah Cornelius Tamra calm give
it a give it a little look see it's a
great website great resource he has a
lot of good textures and stuff too that
he's giving away let's just start
building something out here okay so
usually what I'll do is I'll drop a
person in because that's my scale I'll
know how big this room is gonna be and
I'll just start building this out with
planes
hmm
so I'm holding holding control and when
you drag it'll make a copy so I'm kind
of just shaping it with planes right now
and then I'll come back over this and
start to build it out with maybe maybe a
cube or something depending on what is
what's best
all right so an octane switching between
direct lighting and path tracing direct
lighting I believe I don't know you
maybe only have a couple bounces of
light in the scene but when you switch
to path tracing that's going to bounce
light around a lot more you can see how
the sphere you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of shadow at the bottom of
this thing and a little bit at the top
as well these corners is pretty dark
compared to the light that's coming from
the left side of screen hitting this on
the right and if you switch to path
tracing you can see how it's a much more
realistic lighting setup now there's
times when direct lighting and path
tracing look very similar but in this
case when we're doing an interior scene
you're gonna want to use path tracing at
the end of the day because that's going
to bounce the light around a whole bunch
more and you can see the difference
between those if you go to compare and
enable a be comparison and you want to
store this scene switch to direct light
and you can you know see the difference
between direct lighting and path tracing
and I'm sure it's similar for all the
other renderers out there if you're
using blender it's the e V renderer or
if you're using Arnold or redshift you
know I'm sure there's very similar
toggles there for direct lighting and
path tracing but for the sake of setting
this up right we're fine with direct
lighting we can uncheck that let's save
our scene
alright let's see maybe let's go for let
me go for like a circular setup
hmm something like a pool of water in
the center of a room or something a
circular room like this and I'm just
knocking this stuff out I'm just
blocking it out really pretty quick here
and you know you want to start as
general as possible and then get more
detailed so first thing I'm going to do
is find my frame but only after I build
out the scene
something like that and that will be
they'll be like a pool of water inside
there so we can add a cylinder and that
will be our water right there and then
let's see you can like walk around the
outside of this thing but let's put like
a roof on this so it'll get taller and
then we'll duplicate it again and we'll
inset it so that you have like a bit of
like a ceiling and if we can get a
camera like in here like right at this
point and we get a nice little
wide-angle view of this let's see
actually let's do this right so I'm in
camera view right here you can see this
little toggle it's checked so we'll
uncheck that we'll get out of camera
view and then you should see your camera
right in there yes if you select your
camera let's just zero out all of these
settings as well as the rotation so we
have just the camera on the ground right
down here another little trick if we go
back into camera view and we go to
options and uncheck the check camera
option here we can dip out a camera view
but our render will still stay in camera
view so we can actually start to see oh
wait that's not right
that didn't work didn't work how I
thought it would work anyway let's keep
going so it's easier now to control our
camera because we've zeroed out the
settings if we go into like our 4 panel
view and go to the top we can see what's
going on here let's go wide angle on
this start with like a 24 and let's get
our aspect ratio right 16:9 it's fine
this is like 1920 by 1080 your standard
like HD video we can lock the ratio and
bring that down to 960 by 540 so that we
can get a little bit smaller render here
even smaller
let's go 600 480 by 270 super tiny
that's okay because we're still blocking
things out so now we want to tilt our
camera up so we could do that by hitting
our when you have your camera selected
and rotating this little guy there now
it'd be awesome if we could see the
entire ceiling of this thing so it'd be
the equivalent of you know basically
what we did right there we switched it
from a 24 to a 12 and you're getting you
know this setup right here which is
looking pretty sweet and I think if we
light and texture this and throw in a
you know a tree in the middle of this
little pond right here I think it can
look incredible so let's let's start
doing that I wonder if a 12 is the right
move or if we should just make the
geometry bigger at the end of the day I
know that the geometry here is going to
need to be it needs more segments
all right so if you had an object you
can just crank those segments to 100 and
you can see how like you see this blocky
low-poly
looking deal here we just need to up the
segments now we're getting a bit bit
more detail in there let's see if this
camera goes back any further going back
in the top view select your camera and
you'll notice here that if we are in the
local view the camera is gonna go down
gradually over time that's because we
rotated the camera or we tilted the
camera up a little bit so you're gonna
make sure in cinema you're gonna hit W
and that's going to switch between local
and world view and that will bring the
camera straight back when you're in
world view it'll be the same deal in
blender I doubt the hotkey is W but you
want to switch between local and world
view I like this uh this camera angle
this 12 this is actually really nice we
can maybe 15 no 12 is 12 the move I like
it a lot just for just the test it lets
literally duplicate everything so let's
get out of our camera view zoom out here
this is our setup let's group all this
stuff and we'll just call that scene
control drag to duplicate and we'll move
it over to the side here and I'm just
gonna do a test and see if I make the
actual like architecture larger if it'll
give us a different look because that
way we'll be able to go from instead of
a 12 we can go to like maybe a 24 so
let's try something let's see if this
works if we see how could we scale this
all uniformly
let's select our scene let's hit the the
enable access tool or l and then you can
move the axis around and we'll put it
right in the place of the camera you can
hit L to turn that off and now when we
scale this scene right we had the the
null object or this folder selected and
we move the axis for that folder and if
we have that selected hit T and scale
things up
that should work let's go into camera
view and let's scale things up try again
Oh weird okay not doing anything that's
hmm probably because everything's
relative
we should say that to 24 and yeah I
guess it's not doing anything because
everything is relative you know
everything's everything is moving at the
same the same rate or the same size
right so let's just try scaling up let's
see how would we do this we would scale
these cylinders and move them forward
and up
okay and then we would need to scale we
would need more room here our outermost
cylinder would need to be scaled up and
then we move we can move the camera
outside of the scene and then move
everything besides the camera forward so
that our camera is backed up against the
wall something like that
but we can raise the camera a little bit
to see in the into that pool and here's
a good example of the local versus world
view right this is moving the camera
locally that's for that's forward for
the camera and that's up for the camera
in terms of how its oriented and if you
hit W you're going to world view and now
that is moving things up and down
depending on the world so let's go up a
little bit let's come in and honestly I
think we had it in our other view here
so it's that versus that and I think
this is way better so let's delete that
test we did this is gonna be our scene
okay so definitely michael says we
should make a little island inside the
pool that grows the tree and the tree
should be has hanging lights ooh okay
interesting let's um I like that let's
do a little island here where the tree
will be growing from so we can do that
as pretty easily will hop out of camera
view and let's I'm hitting s to snap to
any object I have selected and it's such
a handy tool if you ever get lost if
you're you know your viewing window just
goes crazy like it just did right there
wow this perfect timing hit s and it'll
snap it back to your scene if you hit H
it'll show all right so if you have like
say a cube way over there
you hit H it'll frame everything that
you have in your in your scene and if
you want to go to the cube just hit s
you're you're in so like that hit us
again you know it's just good good way
to navigate and I feel that when you hop
into a 3d program for the first time
it's very daunting because you feel like
you're you know stuck in quicksand
you're trying your hardest to get
forward and it's not working so that's
that's because you don't know how to
navigate you literally don't know how to
navigate the program same for same for
After Effects or Photoshop if you don't
know how to navigate the program the new
program you're in it's gonna feel very
slow and just gonna feel like so much
energy is being spent learning how to
just move so I think the most important
thing when hopping into a new program is
learning how to move around the program
and if you can get comfortable with
moving around the program right then you
know then you can start thinking on top
of that then you don't have to worry
about oh how do I move how do I you know
how do I get my viewport right you're
thinking about what do I put in my
viewport so really make sure you guys
understand how to move around in the
program that you're using whether it's
blender or Maya or 3ds max or Photoshop
or substance you know whatever whether
you're making music - same deal just
know how to navigate around and be
comfortable with that so then you can
feel like you're running you know you
don't to be through be crawling through
quicksand anymore
okay let's make the little the little
island so we will oh we do will
duplicate one of these things let's try
the cube so I have the cube selected and
if I hit T for scale and hold control
you'll make a new one and because it's
being scaled down it's being scaled on
all axes it is disappearing under the
water there we'll hit E and bring it up
and we'll continue to scale it down
all right and and at the end of the day
like we might just actually make a
little island but this is kind of like a
little pedestal for this thing to be on
we can switch this out pretty easily for
a cylinder I'm holding control so okay
here's here's a good tip to let's say in
this case we don't need to do that we
don't need to hold control because it's
in the center of the scene but if you
want to spawn a new primitive object in
the center of another object you have in
the scene all you have to do is hold
control and the thing will be spawned
right in the center of that so that's
another thing too for navigation right
let's take this person duplicate them
drag them out here for a little test and
rotate rotate them all crazy right and
what let's say we want to give them a
top hat and it's like well I could just
we know it's gonna be a cylinder but
okay the cylinders are way over there
now I'm kind of lost
well that's why you hit s snap to it and
you're gonna try and drag this cylinder
all the way over to this guy and you're
gonna try on the line it line it up so
that it's on his head and it's already
difficult because things are all janky
and you guys get it right this is a
difficult process you could you do that
or select your guy hold ctrl and spawn a
sphere right and it's going to spawn
right on him and the Orang take the
orientation is gonna be correct too so
right now we're at world orientation if
you hit W will go to local orientation
bring it up scale it down right now he's
got a funny hat so that is a good way to
navigate the program right
the easier it is to do stuff the faster
you're going to get the idea from your
head out onto the screen right into the
program so what were you what were we
doing we were making a sphere or a
cylinder here because we want like a
little pedestal for that thing to be on
okay next we need a tree
we're missing a tree so I'm actually
using a plug-in called Forester and it
does cost money but it's awesome if you
guys are looking for free trees I'm sure
you can go to turbosquid dot-com right
and type in tree and set the price to
free now you have two hundred and twenty
two trees that are for free
you have blender files you can search by
let's see format you can search by obj
is a file type that works across all 3d
software same deal for FBX that should
be universal now you have your your
specific file types if you're in 3ds max
you'd search for max c 40 obviously maya
blender right you have all those
different file types but at the end of
the day you can just search for FBX and
obj and know that that'll work across
all platforms so you can download this
one this is cool tree it looks really
nice same deal here this is kind of like
a fortnight II cartoon looking tree and
yeah you can just scrub through here and
grab a cool-looking train that is free
you can also pay for trees if you'd like
you got a little bonsai tree a willow
tree or something yeah you guys get the
idea but I'm gonna use Forester so let's
see Forester
we will make a forester tree and will
render our scene here and it is looking
like it needs some leaves let's see here
which tree should we do is so this is
the one I did last time there's a
crazy-looking tree we do a weeping
willow and you can always change this
later under tree parameters you can set
the let's say viewport levels and render
levels should have leaves why is it not
it leaves
how's everybody doing yeah it's tough
I feel like anytime you open a new
program you feel like you're in
quicksand or anytime you're doing
something new that's the feeling but the
more you practice it the faster you'll
get and you want to get to the point
where you're flying through the program
and that's when I think you when you're
flying through a program that I don't
know if that's master level but maybe
maybe if you're like flying in a jet
through the program then maybe that's
master level but yeah everyone's gonna
start in quicksand and then they're
gonna get out of the quicksand and
they're gonna be crawling and they're
gonna kind of stand up and start walking
and then they'll eventually get running
and then you'll start sprinting and then
you'll be jumping and then then you'll
be flying through the program and that's
that's what you want to get to it just
takes time it looks like this render is
not rendering so yes c40 is not
responding I'm gonna reboot this
Michael thanks for joining trying to
find a time that works for everybody so
yeah I appreciate you stopping by for a
little bit man this will be on my
youtube channel it's not gonna be live
but the full video will go out onto my
punisher channel so you can be able to
catch it there Oh Nick
yes okay so for sirs awesome and I also
have hot for D as well that's basically
a a like ocean generator it stands for
Houdini ocean something oh I think you
have to like apply it to a a plane yeah
and it gives you these like super
realistic ocean ocean Maps let's see
this thing's the best it's free you can
up the segments right and you get some
really cool like ocean texture here and
it's using a displacement map you can
turn this up so it's really nice right
throw a nice little texture on that and
it animates really well - let me see
where's the animation on this tie is it
time yeah look at that it's so cool I'll
see if I can't throw a link to this
plug-in into the description of this
video after we're done but let's get
back to it here we are
let's throw our tree in and start
texturing this thing alright so I kinda
want to go for another concrete vibe all
around here so let's get ourselves some
concrete textures
all right actually you know what before
we texture
let's light so let's grab an octane
daylight system and rotate it down
straight 90 boom that's looking cool if
you set the if you click the little Sun
tab here and set the turbidity to a
higher to a higher number that's
basically gonna start turning your son
into an overcast day so if that goes to
five you can start to see you know
things are getting smoothed out a little
bit you can crank the power and you can
see here look look at a look at this
render you see how there's no light on
the like bottom part of the ceiling if
we switch to path tracing it's gonna
fill all that stuff in but for the sake
of setting up our scene and stuff we can
keep that on direct lighting for now
let's um let's add an HDRI image so I'm
gonna make an octane sky right click it
I have hgri link from greyscale gorilla
it is the best plug-in for adding HDR
eyes quickly to your scene all you have
to do is hit the little that little tab
here for your environment and click and
drag the texture boom into the signal
and then now you can launch the browser
and look through all of your HDRI images
these are all grayscale gorillas HDRI
images they are the best I love them
they actually later this year they're
coming out with a little space
HDR I pack and they they hooked it up in
the meantime so shout out to to
grayscale gorilla there really are the
best let's turn off our Sun so we can
see what's going on oh come on computer
there we go yeah so you can see the HDR
I like the space HDR is lighting our
scene if we set that to path tracing
it'll really get in here and give you a
cool super cool look you know we could
have a Zen garden in space
when it's cool cuz you can like rotate
this stuff around you can find the right
angle on that
wow that's pretty crazy
but yeah let's um let's find the right
one so we have like some end-of-day HDRI
images here this is actually pretty nice
going to set my image to linear and you
can rotate this around to give you the
right lighting you want and kind of get
like a center center lighting like that
and you want to combine this with your
sunlight right so let's change the
turbidity back to 2.2 and let's mess
with the angle of the Sun so we can like
find the best position like that would
be pretty sweet
right there
or something like that it's pretty cool
let's go with this for now we can always
change it later right
now if you want to combine it with your
HDRI image you would click little the
little daylight tag and scroll down
until you see this little checkbox mix
sky texture you check that and it's
gonna use your sunlight as they like
direct source and it's going to use the
HDRI image you know - as your sky
basically so let's see if we rotate the
sky around you can still see how this
guy's being used in helping with
lighting the scene here and I still want
it to be more of an overcast situation
so let's take the turbidity of the sky
here and set that to like five or
something and let's roll with this for
now I'm 640 by 360 I'm get a bit more
resolution on that how's everybody doing
we are making a interior Zen garden
space last week I made one and like it
turned out really cool and actually you
guys liked it a lot but I want to make
another one I want to do something a bit
more symmetrical with a bit more light
involved
yeah I don't know if you guys saw the
video on corridor crew where we did
think it's Valentine's Day Valentine's
Day challenge and we had to do make an
image in 45 minutes and for some reason
my computer blue screen twice it kept
crashing and I was only out able to get
out an image of like just flowers but
you know I I was happy with how it
turned out all right so let's start
lighting this thing um or texture I'm
sorry texturing this thing okay we can
do like concrete all around here and
well I know we want this little central
part here to be like a little water
fountain so let's do the water real
quick I'm gonna make a glossy material
and drop it on there and we'll set the
index to zero so it's basically a mirror
a reflective mirror and let's grab okay
the cylinder that it's on right we'll
give it some height segments here so
I'll show you guys what I'm talking
about
I'm sorry not height segments we want
let's see what do we want we want to
chop this so we want to have different
segments coming up to this point and for
some reason I don't think this thing a
thing you can add with the just the base
primitive so we'll hit C make it
editable we'll go to our little edge
mode here so we're selecting our edges
will hit ul I'm sorry we'll hit uh you
why is that at the 1k oh yeah KL is the
hotkey for that and KL is loop path cut
you can go to select and hit loop go to
select and hit is it in here somewhere I
don't know where it is loop path cut you
can also hit shift C and hit loop path
cut and it'll be right there KL it's
probably under mesh or something anyway
if you hit if you click once right here
you'll have this little tab up here and
you can you know shift around where the
cuts gonna be just set it to like 50%
and start adding a bunch of cuts that's
good hit enter
back to selection mode and that will
allow us to hopefully we can zoom in
here that is going to allow us to add
some displacement to this cylinder and
you can't displace the geometry without
geometry so that's why we added all
those cuts if you hold down shift and
drop down your modifiers you can throw a
displacer on it and in the displacer if
you go to shading and you let's throw
some noise on
and you can see already that gives us
kind of like a lake or a pond look
ripples in the water you can take the
cylinder hold alt and throw a
subdivision surface on it and that'll
smooth things out even further right and
then you can mess with the displacement
so we can you know you can up the
contrast so it's a bit more extreme or
you could just you know keep the
contrast at zero and go to the displacer
tab go to object and work the strength
down or up a little bit and that's just
gonna give you a little bit of texture
to the lake or to our pond
okay so let's um let's crank that a
little bit more actually there you go
now you can start to see a little bit of
texture in there okay
so I think the next thing we need to do
is grab like a concrete texture and
start to color this thing
magnificent Ben welcome I'm glad you're
joining us thanks for watching the last
tutorial and I'm glad he caught us on
his live one ooh what do I think about
moonlight I think moonlight would be
really nice and we can mess with that we
can mess with that once we you know get
going you always change the lighting but
this is actually a good way for us to
you know kind of see where we're going
and then we can get more specific more
specific you can always back up and
change the lighting or change the camera
angle so let's get some concrete in here
okay um a couple options for concrete
you know I have the greyscale gorilla
everyday materials collection and that
is basically like stuff that's preloaded
in that you can you know easily drop
into your scene some preset textures
that are really nice we can do that or
we can go to mega scans which I use all
the time mega scans is incredible they
have this is perfect man it's a
gravestone unfortunately but you know we
can throw it in somewhere maybe it's a
grave site you know they have the best
look these textures are incredible and
they're all tile able to alright so you
can see how they'll little tile if you
guys are trying to do you know carrots
just a sea of carrots they got you right
here
super easy here's another Japanese
gravestone oh man it'd be really intense
to do like scatter a bunch of Japanese
gravestones across like you know the
water or something some still pond with
a tree maybe that's what we'll do and
then we can throw some couple worn
soccer balls in their dirty styrofoam
anyway okay guys I'm getting carried
away I literally go to this website all
the time to check all their new stuff we
need concrete so
let's go to do the concrete tab over
here and see what they got stained
concrete wall okay okay what else do we
have you know we have a lot of good
barriers and stuff hmm I'm looking for
like concrete slab material
something like this that's a bit a bit
much though smooth blocks that could be
interesting concrete wall we can try
this let's give this a shot
so I'm gonna log in download that and we
will implement it into our scene so give
me a second while I download this guy's
how's everybody doing are you guys
following along making your own scene or
you just kind of watching
okay
so we have our texture that we can use
so we'll go in here and we'll start
dropping these these different images
onto our texture so we have all these
different tabs and these tabs make up a
texture so let's for example let's go in
real close so that you guys can see what
each one of these objects or each one of
these images is doing to build up the
texture so zoom in right about there
cool so first off we have the albedo
image and that's basically just the
color image right and the mapping is off
it's hard to tell that the mappings off
from this image we're so close but I've
just done this so many times that I know
the mapping is gonna be off so you can
either hit projection here when you have
your image selected that you just
dropped in or you can drag and drop it
the projection and throw it in to the
projection it's the same same thing and
we're gonna want to set that from mesh
UV to box and then that will actually
have it so the image isn't stretched in
weird ways it's not being stretched to
the geometry of the of the shape you
have it's just you know the image tiled
around you know any serve geometry you
have and right now it's looking yeah
it's looking pretty good let's let's
keep going I'm going to take off the
diffuse though so you guys can hopefully
see what the normal map and the bump map
does so I'm a dragon the normal map and
the normal map is basically it's going
to make it appear as if the geometry is
going up or down like it has extra d2
you know it really doesn't have so we'll
put that into the normal tab and you
should see here all these streaks and
that's because the projection is off so
we want to just drag this projection tab
into the projection tab for the normal
and then you can start to see it takes
shape and you know it's a bit it's very
subtle here and maybe with YouTube
compression it's more difficult to see
but let's keep going we have the bump
map and the bump map is going to give us
you know it's very similar to a normal
map a normal map is a bit better in the
sense that it pushes and pulls pixels a
bit more accurately in a bit it pushes
and pulls them left and right as well
and up and down I believe the bump map
is just a fake artificial texture or
face fake artificial detail based on a
black and white map so we'll put that
projection tab on there and well throw
it into the bump tab and then you can
see a bit more detail comes through
let's put our image back on and you can
start to see this concrete wall being
built up next up we have the roughness
and the specular so roughness determines
how light bounces off of the object and
we talked about this last time basically
my phone here let's see so this phone is
zero roughness it's it's a hundred
percent reflective right you can see
very very detailed reflections in the
surface of this phone however the back
of the phone is still technically
reflective but it's a very rough
reflection so that's what the roughness
map determines is what things are rough
versus what things are not
so we'll drag in the roughness map here
and we'll pipe in our projection pipe
the roughness into roughness and same
for specular specular determines like
the iPhone screen was reflective right
but how reflective do you want it to be
that's what the specular determines
right and finally like those are the
basic building blocks of a texture right
there
but finally we can use a displacement
map and the displacement map is actually
pretty cool because it's going to
actually push and pull geometry so let's
throw that projection tab into
projection or into the displacement and
with this placement for some reason you
can't just put it in there but that's
that's because this place when it comes
with a couple options so I'm gonna grab
this displacement node boom right there
and we'll pipe that in and we will pipe
that into displacement and already it's
hard to tell if things look normal or
not well let's grab displacement I'll
set the mid level to 0.5 because
basically it's saying push everything
either up or down and you want it to go
evenly from the middle so that's what
0.5 is height of 10 centimeters is fine
for now level of detail let's crank that
to 4k cuz we can and already like so
this should be working but I know it's
not because I've run into this issue
many times the mapping isn't going to
work properly
I think it's an octane bug
so if we come in here we can see the
displacement map right here it's
stretched thin even though we told it
not to do that because we put the
projection tab on there it doesn't work
for displacement for some reason so
there is a workaround though and you're
going to have to basically come in here
you're going to have to delete the
projection tab for all the images now
everything lines up properly and you're
going to want to control the way the
image is displayed across your geometry
from the actual texture you've applied
here and you're a little like viewer so
it's on this tube this tube lights up so
you want this texture right here and
it's set to UVW mapping we will take
that too it is a tube which is
cylindrical so we'll try a cylinder that
looks ugly
let's try cubic that actually looks
normal cubic usually looks normal let's
zoom in and you can see here that it's
actually looking pretty nice you know
you have a lot of nice detail you have
these little little like marks where I
think maybe that's where they poured the
concrete from
yeah you know it's very subtle but
that's giving you your look
that's for your walls and stuff we can
do like a reflective concrete floor as
well so for that let's just grab you
know you can use the same image if you'd
like but let's um for the sake of speed
here I'm just gonna open up this live DB
viewer and that's where I'm going to
pull some of the greyscale gorillas
everyday materials into the scene
because it's very fast how's everybody
doing everyone hanging in Caleb I'm
working on texturing this semi interior
Zen garden yeah you can totally UV map
stuff in c40 I don't really know how
that's something I need to probably
research but um yeah you should be like
wrap and unwrap stuff I've just never
really dug into that too much alright
how's it going everybody displacement
Ralph says displacement displacement
maps do affect the geometry and get a
little funky if you don't give it enough
to work with exactly so the enough to
work with that he's referring to is the
actual geometry so maybe what we need to
do is give it more give our tube here
more segments to work with so we can
give it like 25 cap segments and we'd
have to make it editable and then we can
come around here hit uy as you AR ùl
what we're looking for
dang I all the sudden just forgot my
shortcuts ul UK what was it called as
like loop path yeah okay L kale that's
what I was looking for yeah we can come
in here just make a whole bunch of cuts
boom enter and then now the the
displacement should be a bit more
detailed also remember from two streams
ago we were talking about how no edge is
sharp there's no such thing as a sharp
edge so all of these edges here are
super sharp and technically that is not
that's not correct so what we'll do is
we'll go to our tube here and we'll
bevel those edges and the best way I
know to do that is instead of you know
selecting your edge and beveling it out
like yeah that doesn't work either let's
try that again you know instead of
beveling out your edge like this
normally and baking it in to the
geometry I want to try and edit as
non-invasive as possible that way if
there's ever changes you can make them
you hold tube or you select tube hold
shift and we will use a bevel modifier
when you see how it bevels everything we
don't want it to bevel everything that's
just you know a waste of geometry so you
can use angle right here this little
checkbox you hit that and it's gonna say
well what's the threshold you know I'll
only bevel things that are above the or
let's say I'll only bevel things above
the 94 degree mark and if you set that
below 90 you're only bubbling things
above that right there that degree and
you can you know say oh I want a
subdivision of two on that so it's not
just like a solid line
and that'll give you a more detailed and
realistic scene because light is gonna
catch that edge and it's gonna look
really nice and you see how it catches
the bottom - that's because of our
Bottari
our bevel modifier and when you will do
that - basically all of our edges in the
scene here so this this tube here right
that we have as our like little pond
barrier if you hadn't made your
primitive object editable yet you can
select it and there's actually a little
fill it or fillet I don't know how you
one of those one of those is proper you
check that box and it's going to
actually bake in a little bevel for you
and and bacon is actually the wrong word
you can turn it off right it's fully
editable that's why I try and keep my
objects I guess as well editable is the
right word try and keep them editable
for as long as possible and I try to
keep things as clean as possible so you
don't want to bake in any geometry that
you don't need to bake in I think that's
just the personal preference other
people might do it differently but I do
like this really intense bevel here it
rounds it off in a really cool way okay
let's continue so alright we need to
continue texturing I'm going to grab a
concrete texture from the Live DB
materials thing so actually if you have
octane it comes with live DB and you had
you just have materials ready to go
already we want non-organic
and it looks like they don't have they
don't have concrete for some reason
maybe it's under one of these
Carbon paint cloth glass plastic metal
so this is all built into octane but
recently I added the everyday materials
pack from greyscale gorilla and they
have concrete so for the sake of the
tutorial I'm just gonna grab one of
these and I'll do something pretty
pretty reflective so we can catch some
cool light let's do this one right here
concrete 8 let's download that and it's
gonna pop up right down in here and
we'll drag that onto the floor cool so
we can select that and let's hop out of
our camera view and get right up onto
this floor here so we can see what's
going on
yeah that's concrete we'll come in here
we'll set all of these images we'll
throw a projection tab on them and we
just want to clean up the projection
we'll set it to box that's going to
properly distribute the texture across
all that we could set the transform
we'll set it we'll set it high and see
what we're doing here yeah that looks
nice then you're getting your your
texturing your detail in there I think 5
was good so let's hop back into our
camera and we want this floor to be
pretty reflective so if we if we go to
index which controls the reflectivity of
your material and we set it to 1 it's
gonna be Chrome and you can see how that
gives like a really cool look right it's
a very it's a there's there's there's a
roughness image here plugged in so if we
unplug that you're gonna see how it's
basically just a chrome ground and we
don't want quite that but we have our
roughness tab
that spreads the light across the area
which is very very nice and it's a bit a
bit reflective so we can start to crank
the index back up and right when you get
higher than one for some reason the
image becomes not really reflective at
all eight is about as reflective as one
because one is fully chrome right so
that means eight is just under fully
chrome and then you go down and down and
down and I think somewhere around here
is nice because it still spreads out the
the ground and let's get this barrier
system here going let's bring it down
along with the plane here and the tree
so let's actually start cleaning up some
of this stuff so we have our ceiling
you guys stay organized here because
they'll quickly get out of hand we have
our wall ceiling our wall we'll have our
floor which yeah we have our floor right
here and that the ceiling our wall and
our floor we can group that and just
call that like foundation and then we
have like this pond right so we can
select all the stuff in the pond this is
our water we have our like I don't know
pond wall sure there's a better name for
that and then we have our tree it'll
drop that and call this pond there's our
there's our like island there are trees
on and then the rest is like seeing
stuff and I actually do group all that
the lighting and the camera stuff into a
folder called scene that way you can
just break everything down here and be
as organized as possible so next we want
to texture this like barrier that's
holding our water in all right let's do
mm-hmm let's try the same greyscale
gorilla material and I think we can
brighten it up so let's come into the
node editor and we will drag a color
correction node right on that little
wire that's connecting that it'll pipe
right in automatically and we'll just
set the will set the Gama up to like 1.5
or sorry other way around 0.8 it's gonna
make it a little bit brighter sweet
all right let's work on our island a
little bit so instead of a little
concrete slab like we have here I kind
of want it to actually be oops
I kind of want it to actually be like
you know a rocky kind of surface so I'm
going to actually make a new scene real
quick and see what I have in terms of
rocks so I'm using mega scans again for
the rock stuff and you can go to let's
see if you just type in like 3d asset
you'll get all their 3d stuff which are
is actually like geometry involved it's
not just you know image textures and
they have a lot of really good stuff as
you guys can see and we'll find
something like this but you know more of
an island shape right so we can narrow
down our search and call this 3d asset
and look for rocks and already we're
kind of getting into the territory here
this this is perfect and I think I
already own this let me double check
yeah I believe I do okay so let's build
it real quick and this is super fun
because it's like 3d Legos
we'll grab boom there it is
our rocks right here it's kind of it's
very similar but I think it's will work
so it comes in this is your geometry I'm
hitting n and then B on the keyboard to
switch the shading style you can do that
up here by going to display you see n B
and that's just so you guys can see the
geometry of this it's pretty low poly
right it doesn't look too good but let's
let's build this up this is very
exciting
I'll do a quick HDRI image just so we
can like you know see what this thing
looks like sure here we go so in the
material we're gonna start adding these
images again and I'll do the actual like
color image the diffuse image last so
let's start with the normal map and we
can drag this in and look how much of a
difference this makes and I'll store
this render buffer and enable the a/b
comparison when I throw the normal map
in here check this out look at how much
detail is added just from the normal map
isn't that crazy so this is a way like
you are gonna save a lot of memory and a
lot of computer juice basically and
you're not actually going to have this
geometry this detailed geometry modeled
in to your model here because this is
what we're looking at this is what we're
working with right but when you start
building these things up you get into
super intense detail right here and even
if we zoom in like you can look at that
it's great
let's keep going
that's yeah that's just a normal map
let's do the bump map real quick where's
the bump map here we go drag this guy in
and we'll pipe this guy let's uh let's
do this again right so we'll save our
store the render buffer and we'll throw
the bump map in and to see what it's
actually doing and you see it's giving
us an extra layer of detail across the
board here let's keep going let's store
again and let's bring in our specular
map which determines how reflective this
is gonna be like if you want it to be um
like a shiny wet rocks you know we can
we can crank the specular up a whole
bunch that's not making the biggest
difference but you can still see a
difference here like across the top
let's store that again and let's throw
in our roughness and again that's
determining how the reflection is spread
out across your geometry and again not
the biggest difference because when
you're adding the bump and the normal
Maps it kind of spreads the reflection
out automatically on its own okay what's
next what's next we have I think we can
just go with the color here and pipe
that guy in and we should be seeing
unless unless my computer's gonna crash
there it is we should be seeing the
actual image there
and yeah that's a pile of rocks for sure
some mossy rocks but here check this out
so you see how the edge of everything
here is so there's not a lot of detail
in the edges right like usually you'd
have a little bit of moss coming up here
right and that's what the displacement
map is for the displacement map is
actually going to shift the geometry of
your of your your polygons here so we'll
grab in the deepest displacement map and
remember again with displacement maps
you need this little displacement node
because that's how we tweak our settings
for this for the displacement map and
we'll pipe that into displacement and
you can already see how the geometry
buffs up you know we'll set the store
render and that doesn't look good at all
because it's being dispersed by ten
centimeters that's a lot I think you
only really need one and we'll set the
mid level to 0.5 what if we set it to
two and then we set our level of detail
to 4k because it is a 4k image and you
can see I mean obviously there's a big
difference there because of the the 10
centimeter deal but let's store the
render buffer and let's set our height
down to like 0.1 so it's nothing's
happening and we'll set our global
detail to 256 and you can see look at
the geometry across this like moss it's
actually being displaced and the edge of
this thing it's not very obvious but the
edge is somewhat being affected like
right in here and this is gonna be a lot
more apparent when you're applying a
displacement texture to say like a
sphere and instead of a perfectly you
know a perfect edge it's gonna be Y all
jagged like rocks and stuff last quick
tip for you guys when you're texturing
in octane and I'm sure all the other
textures have
the same deal let's say you have an
image that is black and white only like
say your roughness or your bump or your
displacement you know or your specular
all of those images that are black and
white are using a little bit more RAM
because they actually let me let me
rephrase that all of these images you're
using to build up this texture is all
taking a little bit of RAM away from
your computer and memory away from your
computer and slowing a computer down
just little bit more now with color
there's more information in these color
nodes right but when you're bringing in
black and white images the octane thinks
they're color images and it's using as
much data and as much RAM and memory as
it would be on a colored image but since
these are just black and white images
you don't need to be using all that
computer juice so all you have to do is
select your black and white images go to
type and set it to float and that will
actually spare your computer a little
bit of space and be working just a
little bit faster
it's that builds up it really builds up
when you have a whole bunch of materials
Gilbert oh what's up bud
this guy gets stomping over the keyboard
and then it's over
how's everybody doing
you guys falling along thanks Alex I
appreciate you coming in here man it's
super fun for me I love I love making
these different scenes and whatnot so
thanks for coming by I appreciate all
you guys for watching
you guys are awesome
Gilbert is about four months old he's
chillin right now and then he got Teddy
who's about three years he's a huge cat
he's down there on the ground Oh Gilbert
chill but yeah Gilbert's been great he's
been such a little bud
all right go play all right go play okay
so now that we have our rock asset built
out let's go ahead and place it in our
scene so I'm just gonna copy it move
over to our our other scene and paste it
there it is right in the middle give it
a second it's generating the materials
down to the bottom left you can see it
thinking
yes and Gilbert is adopted from a local
Petsmart and we are super glad to adopt
that little bud he's great
okay let's render our scene and see what
we got
my first instinct is I think we're gonna
need to scale these rocks up they're a
little small but we shall see
we shall see yeah so let's um get out of
camera view and let's let's say you
forget to go out get off camera view and
you just start you know zooming in here
you're like oh no my camera was set and
it was perfect
if you hit ctrl shift Z that will undo
camera moves only then you can get out
of camera view and select your rocks hit
s and it'll snap to it and let's scale
these guys up bring them forward and I
think that'll that'll probably do the
trick here let's bring them up rotate
them a little bit them forward
yeah something like something like that
yeah that looks really cool
so I'll put one in the back and I'll
duplicate it and put one in the front
something like that and then we got a
little island there I I'm not really
digging the fact that everything looks
black and white even though it's a
texture discolor or textured his
concrete so I think I think we need to
add some color into all this somehow hmm
so we could I don't know let's see
what's the move on this
let's try changing out our hgri image
here for something with like a bit of
sky you know some clouds
I'm just kind of cycling through to see
what what is nice aid you guys get a
chance to look at that Spotify playlist
it's in the it's in the description of
this video it's like an ambient playlist
I put together for you guys
hmm see I still just trying to find the
right HDRI image
oh that's nice
that's pretty cool
yeah I like that that's nice and then
we'll mess with our camera settings a
little bit and put on like a vignette
just a little bit and let's get let's
get a look on here I really like
Kodachrome 25 that has a really nice
look to it okay so this tree this tree
needs help
let's throw we need to texture this
thing and it also needs to be a tree so
let's let's do tree parameters
let's go to tree library
okay here we go now we're starting to
get something oh they have bamboo that's
cool
it's a really saturated
I wonder if we can grow the bamboo like
super tall with forester tree parameters
tree size tree grow that's so cool
that's amazing I have like yet to really
mess with this program trunk parameters
segments radius trunk displacement
trunks scale
oh let's set that back to 50 I swear
there's like a size or a height thing on
here is it not under tree parameters
tree size
all right let's see bamboos cool but I'm
not really feeling it let's go back to
the tree library and see what else we
got that's actually pretty cool it
definitely needs the palm trees cool but
don't really like that vibe
that's nice it feels like a bonsai tree
that's some let's mess with that so it
needs leaves that's for sure
so let's go to the e there should be
like a leaf tab or something fruit
leaves there we go
start leaf level leaf multiplier
see if this works are there even leaves
on this thing I feel like yeah there's
leaves on in but not a lot there we go
like five was good yeah okay so David
man I get his last name wrong all the
time David are you or David re EV I
think it's um
he's octane Jesus David David are you
yeah David are you so he um he's
incredible he has like some of the best
octane cinema4d tutorials of all time
honestly it's how I learned how to mess
with cinema 4d is because of him his
website has an incredible resource
that's David are you calm
let's see David are you calm and this
website is the best if you go to
resources he has all these cinema4d
octane tutorials if you guys are trying
to learn this is the best place to do so
and he actually had a tutorial on how to
do trees in octane and Forester is how I
figured out or David is the one who told
me about Forester and here's a little
tip so basically let's see if we can't
replicate this you see how the light is
being blocked by these leaves like the
light isn't shining through these leaves
and we we want the leaves to have a bit
of subsurface scattering to them and
subsurface scattering is what happens if
you like shine a flashlight behind your
ear you're gonna see a bit of you know
the veins in your ear or the red the
light shining through your ear right or
like your finger with the flashlight
same deal and you have that with leaves
you know they're not made of steel you
know the light is gonna get through
these leaves somehow and currently with
the way octane or with foresters setup
you don't get that so how do we do that
let's come into our leaf material here
and first off we need to convert them to
octane materials so you'll select those
two and you go to materials convert
materials and
and select materials again remove unused
and that is going to change on on me
undo that real quick okay something's
not working okay I think I just needed
to re-render
the scene so again let's go into our
leaf material and it is set to diffuse
versus glossy and now the leaves also
have a bit of highlight to them so we're
gonna want to mess with that as well we
want to combine a reflective leaf that
is transparent but first we'll start
with the transparency because you can
only do with a diffuse material you
don't have the option to make things
shiny and in a glossy or shiny material
you don't have the option to make things
transparent like with subsurface
scattering so we're gonna start with the
subsurface scattering first and that is
under transmission it's set to black and
it's set to zero and hopefully if we
crank this number up you should see the
light start to pass through these leaves
there you go yeah the light is starting
to get through these leaves and if we
set this to kind of like a green color
and I'll just tab to the leaf color
there you can start to see them you know
dispersing that kind of that light the
light is passing through the leaves like
that now you set that to a brighter
color and they're gonna you know they're
going to disperse that hue of color
there so that looks nice but we also
want them to be reflective as well we
want them to catch the sunlight so what
we'll do is make a mix material we're
gonna combine both so let's copy if you
hold ctrl and drag you'll make a copy of
that leaf
and let's switch it to instead of a
diffuse material we're gonna switch it
to a glossy material and let's apply
this glossy material and real quick
let's do comparison so we'll store the
render buffer here and we'll drag our
leaf onto our tree and you should see
here it should update oh why are we not
seeing a difference maybe have to read
render the scene there you go
okay so this is this like greener leaf
is the sunlight passing through our
leaves and this darker leaf is our
original leaf but with kind of like a
highlight a specular highlight on it so
you guys can see the difference there
let's compare store this render buffer
and let's start to crank up the specular
so roughness will disperse the
reflection so let's crank the roughness
and see if we can't get a highlight on
these things and I'm failing to you
right now let's say we set this leaf to
like really reflective maybe bring the
roughness down a little bit and this all
could be determined too unlike the angle
of the Sun so for instance the tree
might catch more of a reflection from a
certain angle and actually you guys can
see it there yeah you can see how the
it's catching that reflection there
that's what we're going for so we want
to combine these two leaves and we'll do
that using a mixed material so if you go
to materials make a mixed material and
it's going to give you material one and
material two we'll drag those into that
slot there and it's going to on by
default makes them half in half and we
just need to replace our leaf on the
tree with the mixed material leaf
and then we can see here how we have
more of a just a better looking leaf
so let's rerender our scene there you go
so this is our leaf looking looking now
with our updates and this is just the
specular version let me see if I can
just do like a before and after here for
you guys
so I'll duplicate the leaf let's turn
this off and put this leaf on here
render the scene
how's everybody doing right now you guys
hanging in there Vegard I I mix you ask
a good question he says do you make the
models yourself or do you use something
like a preset or a mix of both of them
when you're making stuff and the answer
is both I recognize that it was actually
something I learned very recently and
I've heard Ian Hubert say this as well
as blender guru and they both have the
opinion that if you're making a scene
like a big scene like we're doing right
now it is a combination of a lot of
different objects you know we have a
pond we have a tree we have you know the
the the foundation the walls and
everything and this is a very simple
example but basically you're not you're
not showing that you can make a tree
you're not modeling a tree and saying I
made this tree you're you're showing a
scene that you can compose right so
there's no harm and downloading a tree
or there's no harm and downloading you
know even a person or any model you want
there's no harm in downloading in that
any of that stuff and people make money
through asset packs and whatnot and you
bring them all together to make your
final image and you know unless you're
saying you know I put all this time into
modeling this house and bam here's this
house I modeled like that's awesome you
can certainly do that and that's what we
did the last couple streams with that
tank right we model the whole tank
together and I love modeling so I'm
going to be doing it anyway you know but
if it's something more specific and
unique you might have to model it but if
it's something like a bicycle or a car
you can download those things very
easily and just use them in your scene
and get going very quickly so it looks
like cinema is crashing again so let's
let's try this one more time
we'll the 87 says that the ambien tracks
make him sleepy I don't know yeah I
guess they inspire me more so than put
me to sleep and I do listen to them when
I go to bed but I love writing and I
love directing and I love coming with
ideas I love coming up with scenes and
the ambient music helps me and inspires
me to come up with more scenes and you
know it helps me see something in my
head the music helps me see something in
my head and then eventually I can you
know put it out either whether it's on
paper or in 3d so yeah that's that's
that's why I love that hammy music it's
very cinematic okay so it crashed and
we're going to have to remake that leaf
but I'll do it in two seconds here I
really appreciate you guys really do
thank you so much I hope that you guys
are learning stuff I hope we're learning
stuff together please use that discord
server join the discord server the link
to it is in the description of this
stream hop on there and let's just start
talking about all the different
tutorials we want to see because I'll be
here every Saturday from 12:00 to 2:30
doing something cool and new so let's
remake this leaf real quick it's gonna
be super fast so as a recap all right
because you got to do things more than
once if you want to learn something we
have we're gonna mix two leaves together
we want a glassy leaf and a leaf that
has light passing through it so the
first one will do is the leaf that has
light passing through it it's a diffuse
material in octane so we're gonna go to
the transmission tab and actually that's
already set up for us we just crank this
float texture up and we set the color to
green next thing we're going to want to
do is go to duplicate that
we're gonna want to go to the basic tab
and set it to glossy set it to colossi
and we can crank the roughness just a
little bit right and we will up the
index a little bit as well okay like
1.33 or something and then you use a
mixed material to combine those so you
can go to material mix material and you
guys actually noticed that I have like a
little tab here of all the go to octane
things that I use and you can make this
anything you want in cinema but I've
said it's just like an octane tab so I
can click these buttons and make new
things down here and actually the way
you do that it's pretty simple you go to
window and you'll go to customize and I
believe there is a new palette thing
here that you can pull and you should be
able to just click and drag this
anywhere you want and basically you drop
it in there it'll make a fresh tab and
then you can you know as you're going
through here you wanna have youth yeah
sorry
getting all mixed up here you can grab
anything you want click and drag it and
put it into say we look something up
with shift C and you just want like a
bevel tool you can click and drag that
and it'll be placed you see that little
white line it'll be placed right up in
there and now you will have the bevel
tool because you use it a lot as a
button right there okay
so let's throw our two leaves into our
mix material and then let's throw the
mixed material onto our tree and then we
should be in business so let's wrap this
scene up
you
oh man okay so Mathias actually is a
good point you say he says maybe add
some plants growing in from the outside
of the hole and maybe some green stains
on the wall from top down like water
flowed into the pool from above that's
really nice
it's a really really really good idea
yeah have some ivy hanging from like
this concrete up here would be sweet
so that can certainly be done I don't
know if we're gonna have time in the
stream to do all that but we'll try so
you guys can see like the light is being
picked up here on this tree a bit better
we can go into the leaf with
transmission and crank that a little
further and that'll kind of brighten up
the leaves a bit more all right so our
rocks have turned black that's because
we just need to relink those materials
sometimes that happens you can easily do
that by just dragging and dropping the
images onto these little image tabs here
and everything will be reloaded pretty
easily but yeah sometimes that happens
if you crave if it crashes or if you
close it without saving or something or
you know I honestly don't really know
why it happens I it's how it happens to
me a lot but yeah I'm just really in
real inking all of these guys so it's so
hard to tell where all of these okay
there you go then we have displacement
and finally Roughness I believe yeah
alright and you can see the leaves are
back and the rocks are back alright
continuing on here let's just change the
light a little bit
and let's see about adding some fog
because that certainly spices things up
so there's a lot of different ways to
add fog in cinema 4d one way is to
select your octane daylight system and
it's actually the little tab here go to
medium and hit add fog and you'll see it
uh appear down here and when you change
the medium radius it'll start to change
how your fog how the light in the fog
work together so that is there's like a
threshold here where the thought is the
fog is so thick you can't see anything
you can see how the fog is like blocking
the Sun here that's pretty cool
we have path tracing is gonna be what
you want for fog let's see so absorption
yeah said it's like just off-white and
then scattering is just a little bit
darker than that
and I'm honestly just messing with these
settings to see what works
Wow let's stick
hmm so that's one way okay you can
uncheck that to go back to normal and if
we add an octane fog volume this will
start to crunch your system pretty
intensely but if you play it smart you
should be alright so basically the voxel
size editor let's crank that to a
hundred
and you'll see how in the viewport you
basically get these like little little
sheets right to display what the fog is
doing and looking like if you set it to
5 it is well let's save because it might
crash our system if you set it to a
really little number you see how this is
gonna crank up really intensely yeah if
you said that to one you're gonna
explode so don't do that I'll set it to
100 stretch it out stretch it out bring
it down and let's make it taller and now
we have a layer of fog inside of our
little tree dome and in the viewport
it's gone completely black because if
you go to medium and you go into this
little window here you have your
absorption in your scattering you're
gonna want to set your density down to
like one and even one is intense
so try point one and even point one is
intense so let's bring the fog down into
the room so we're all like everyone's in
here together right let's um crank the
scattering phase because that'll allow
the light to like filter in through the
fog a bit more in a direct way so as you
crank that up let's try
let us try taking the absorption up to
let go white like that
yep so this the absorption should be a
little bit brighter than the scattering
and you can see how that's looking a
little foggy and if we crank the
sunlight settings let's go
power of three you can see how that kind
of like starts to filter in then from
here let's tweak the volume let's go
like 0.05 so it comes down a little bit
and it's very subtle it's a very subtle
thing so I'll you know I feel like
that's as far as we'd want to go so I'll
uncheck that just so we can get back to
dealing with our image and we'll take
the sunlight settings down to again um
yeah let's see if we can't get some Ivy
hanging down from from the outside or
maybe just something like maybe we maybe
download some of those some of those
gravestones from mega scans and put them
and line them you know around this thing
here it could be interesting or we could
do different plants and stuff so let's
try that since I already have some
plants loaded up pretty quick let's get
out of a cane camera view come back here
and let's basically set the area where
we want to grow the plants so we'll do
let's go back into camera view and see
we basically needed to go from this
point here all the way around at this
point there so let's do like from here
to there
will select this tube that has the
geometry where we're going to be wanting
to plant the plants on so that's in our
foundation our ceiling we'll go to the
polygon mode and let's just select like
let's select all of all of the whole top
piece a quick way to do that would be to
select everything control a go into our
side view and then deselect everything
except well deselect everything except
for the little top bit
maybe hold control and go to point mode
and just get rid of all those points so
now we just have that top chunk of
points selected hold ctrl again and when
you when you when you're holding ctrl
and switching between these different
modes you're grabbing it's basically
saying oh I have all these polygons
selected but what if I want to select
all those points
hold ctrl select points and then all
those points will be selected but let's
go to polygon holding ctrl and if you
hit you P on the keyboard that will
break off those polygons into a new
little piece of geometry so you can see
here how we broke off
oh sorry hang on one sec you guys can
see here how we broke off just that
little ring because that's where we're
gonna want the plants to be growing on
is right here so let's bring it back
down where it was and we're gonna use
something called octane scatter and it's
going to scatter a certain thing across
the surface of any geometry we want we
want and in this case it's going to be
what we just made right here so let's
call this we'll just call that soil
because that's gonna be growing our
plants all right we'll call it plant
ring and now if you don't have octane
you can also do this with cinema's
cloner so let's do it with that first
just show you guys let's just make a
cube bring it up scale down a little bit
and that'll be like a place holder for
our plants you guys get an idea of how
this works so basically you're gonna
want to clone this cube right so if you
hold down alt with the cube selected and
go to mograph and hit cloner that's
going to clone our cube and the alt
thing by the way when you hold alt
that's just automatically putting this
cube as a child of the cloner here
so you can see how the cloner it's a
linear cloner and we're just going by
three right so your count is three we
can set it to five and it's a linear
cloner you see the mode right here we
want to set it to object which means
we're going to clone across an object
and looking for an object right here so
all we'll do is grab our plant ring I'll
delete the bevel on that we'll grab our
plant ring drag it into the object there
and you can see how they're distributed
across you know this area here and if
you crank up that number to like 200 you
can see how it's distributed distributed
across that and we go back into our
camera view and you can see if all of
these were plants would be pretty cool
looking now
you can do a cool thing where actually
there's a little check box for enable
scaling that's fun I guess it scales
them all proportionally but if you want
to mix things up a little bit um and
make things a bit more random you can do
something pretty cool select your cloner
go to mograph effector and make a random
effector where is it there it is and
that randomly moves around all of these
objects you have in your cloner and by
default it has the position affected by
50 centimeters across the XY and Z so we
can uncheck that because they're already
randomized but the thing I'm seeing is
like rotation and scale so what if you
want your plants to be a little bit
bigger but some of them also smaller
check scale and now you have options you
can scale it by 2 right so some of them
scale up by 2 some of them scaled down
by 2 you can do the same across all
these different you know at your at your
XY and z coordinates and that's actually
a cool way to get you some really cool
like Griebel textures there
let's go back see what we're doing if
you want to scale it uniformly which
let's say you have a model of a plant
and you don't want to stretch it in a
way that seems abnormal you can hit
uniform scale and uniform scale will
just scale everything up or down
uniformly right so you can have some
plants that are a little bit bigger some
plants that are a little bit smaller
right absolute scale what does that do
absolute scale I believe scales things
up only if you have absolute scale
unchecked it'll scale things down so I
like that
and then lastly rotation check rotation
and this one I love because you know it
affects rotation and it just has a
really cool look to it some plants might
be going that way some plants might be
going that way and some plants are spun
all around like that and that'll really
give you a natural look when you drop
plants in there as opposed to a cube so
let me drop some plants in here and see
what happens
hmm castor oil plants we have dry grass
we have dry plants Paspalum these are
all words I have no idea
I don't know plant names here let's try
that and see what we have okay so these
plants are models I'm going to need to
grab these really quick also from mega
scans so if you just type in plant you
get you know a whole bunch of different
plants you can use and that's what I'm
sourcing from for this let's see let's
see okay two seconds so I'll pull these
plants up oh snap we got ivy we got
creeper ivy yes what does that look like
okay wonderful yeah
so I got some cool Ivy stuff here so
basically we will drag this down and you
have look at look at this right so this
doesn't mean anything this is just a
bunch of polygons right but let's build
this out real quick we'll throw that
down we will render our scene all right
that looks like a bunch of nothing and
let's just start dragging those pictures
onto here and you'll see how quickly
this will transform is gonna be awesome
so let's see
okay so here is our color image and we
also have an opacity image and the
opacity is really what's going to make
this see that looks awesome
there it is see how see like how the the
opacity totally makes this it's just
chipping away at the bits that aren't
the leaf right and keeping just the leaf
so let's keep let's do our normal our
roughness and our bump here so we have
our roughness that goes there into the
roughness tab we have our normal which
gives us a bit more detail in the leaf
and then we have our bump which gives us
also more detail in the leaf okay so we
have that let's actually make this thing
a bit shinier
okay and let's now that we have our
material set up we can actually start
dragging and dropping different versions
here of these leaves because the pack
comes with like 12 different versions
same texture works for each one of these
and we can do like one more maybe two
more which will give us a bit of
randomness to all of this yep
so just applying the same material and
you can see how you get like a lot of
cool variation here let's go one last
one great
sweet okay so I think all these need to
be flipped around like that and we'll go
through each one of these and it looks
like the anchor point is set pretty
normally so let's copy all of these into
our scene and this will actually be
spread across instead of the top like we
originally planned they're gonna be
spread across the wall so let's go back
to our ceiling and let's just select
like this little bit here and what you
pee again
and that will be the bit we copy all of
these plants across so we'll re update
and we'll call this ivy ring and we'll
go to our cloner
and instead of let's see instead of the
plant ring we are going to drag the ivy
ring and you can see how that
automatically updates this is like my
favorite part I love scattering things
and randomizing their position everyone
following along we're almost done here
Oh Scott what's up dude hey man thanks
for joining Scott is an old old old old
friend of mine it's actually how I got
my name pony sure is because we all we
all had this like wrestling this
wrestling company after high school
where we would get together and just
wrestle and it's how I got a scar on my
eye this cuz Scott actually had me in a
headlock and I he let go and I flew into
the corner of a door I'm like bounce off
the door so we went hard definitely and
everyone had their names we were all
really into peer ownage at the time so
everyone's name had the word pone in it
and I think Scott was the Grandmaster
pone and I was the pone sure so welcome
dude I think you been what the Marines
or the army since and that like it's
been his thing but dude I really
appreciate you coming down and checking
this thing out it's super nerdy just
nerding out on cinema4d here so let's
replace these cubes with the plants
instead so all you have to do is instead
of the cube in the cloner you just need
to drag these plants into the cloner and
they should update let's just delete the
cubes and already it's not looking good
so how do we fix this let's turn off the
randomizer and just see what we're
cloning here I'm gonna take the ivy ring
and scale it down because maybe okay
let's um let's hide the ivy ring and
there we go I think now we're getting
something so I hid the ivy ring from the
renderer by hitting these little buttons
right here there's these two buttons and
what you can do is either you can click
the the first time you click one of
these buttons that means it's going to
be visible in your renderer or visible
to you and then with the second time you
click it it's going to turn red and
say I don't want to see it now there's
two buttons the first one is for
viewport and the second one is for a
renderer so if I did the first one it's
green it's gonna say the same if I hit
it red it's gonna go away and disappear
for my viewport which I'm actually cool
with and you want to do the same in the
renderer that's one way of doing it you
can also right-click and set it give it
an octane object tag ID and go to
visibility and say camera visible and
it'll also be turned off that way as
well but it looks like when you turn it
back on with the ID you look at the
shadows so you might want to say shadow
visibility off as well okay so they look
a little small so I think what we can do
is scale them up if you select all of
them here hit T and scale yep it looks
like they're scaling properly that's
nice
we want them to be connected to the wall
so let's go to the ivy ring and scale it
up until they're just touching the wall
like that it's nice and then let's go to
our randomizer let's turn it on and go
to the rotation and uncheck the rotation
the scale is fine it's scaling things up
and down I think that's okay let's set
it to 0.25 instead of 5 and for the
rotation let's zero all these things and
you only want to rotate on the z-axis I
believe yeah so there they can be
swiveling left and right by like 5
degrees or something nothing too crazy
let's go back to the camera view and
it's looking like we're getting some
weird stuff on the right and left side
what is that
yeah what is going on there oh we need
to turn off the IV ring in the renderer
okay so that looks normal
they look a little small and patchy we
need a lot more so let's select the IV
let's scale the IV up like this oh and
that's like dripping down I like that
that is awesome okay and then if you
want to move the position of these
things you can use the IV ring like that
let's rotate it a little bit that is
super cool let's um let's add a lot more
so basically what you're gonna want to
do o scaling it down adds does what we
need it to do you might want to hand
place some of them you know so that
they're kind of like drooping over the
edge as opposed to just hanging like
that but I do like you know this kind of
movement here where they're dripping
down in the foreground so let's um
actually scale up the IV ring the thing
that the IV is being scattered across
we're gonna scale up that geometry just
on the y-axis so it's getting taller so
that's gonna push the IV up a bit
alright and if you go to the cloner you
can add a lot more so instead of 200
let's go 300
and I think you just need to kind of
like push and pull some of these a
little bit because you would want like a
top piece that is totally connected to
the top you like it wouldn't make sense
for Ivy to be just hanging like this
without having been like drooped over
the side so you know what I'm kind of
feeling like it'd be cool to change out
the ground for an actual forest floor I
think that could be awesome and you and
honestly um yeah there's a lot of cool
stuff you could do here um we could
probably change out this tree for tree
with like pink leaves or something like
a cherry blossom tree to get more
contrast here because the the IB is kind
of bleeding into the tree and the trees
bleeding into the ivy so we could switch
out the tree for something a bit
brighter let's try uh let's go to our
tree library yeah like what is this one
it looks pink here in the in the
viewport but it's not showing up
oh there we go that is awesome
leaves we can maybe change the leaf
color let's try and do that I think we
can just go in here select both of these
leaves if you have them both selected
they both have defuse tabs so you can
probably throw in a RGB or now color
correction let's see yeah
color correction and go into that and
change the hue and that should start
shifting the colors around
and the gamma can go or we can take the
brightness up to like to saturation with
the saturation goes to zero the
brightness goes or the gamma goes to
like 0.5 and you have like a white you
have white leaves here it's actually
pretty cool let's make them pink so
let's take the saturation to like 0.5 or
something
she's got to get the humor right so I'm
looking down here okay there we go
there's a red leaf we'll take the
saturation 0.5 and the gamma to like 0.5
as well and that'll start to get us kind
of a pink leaf 0.35 and we can change
out the back ground for let's see maybe
something more overcast or a night scene
like this oh that's weird
well that's pretty crazy
interesting interesting
I really appreciate you guys stopping by
and I'm glad that you guys are learning
stuff from this it's really cool so I'm
just trying to get the lighting right
and I can mess with this for so long but
that's looking pretty good if we want to
fix this top row we can make another
strip of polygons here across the top
and do another round of cloners that
just deals with the top ring so let's
try that real quick so we'll select our
IV ring let's check it out in a viewport
let's hold ctrl and scale it up we can
hit T to scale it down and we'll line it
up just so that it's just on the little
top piece let's crunch it down even more
so these the IV has no choice but to
spawn really just right there on the top
we will let's see so that's our top ring
we'll call it top ring let's duplicate
our cloner first let's turn it off
before we duplicate it because we don't
to get too crazy let's control drag it
will rename these two IV cloner and then
we'll call this top IV cloner and we'll
tell the top IV cloner to reference top
ring here and let's let's turn it on and
see what we got
[Music]
and there you go you can see how the IV
is coming from the top and drooping down
that's what we want and then now when we
turn on our other IV cloner you can
really see that stuff droop down like
that I think it's awesome really good
idea I forget who it was but thank you
as an awesome idea oh what's up Eli sup
Eli turn those some c40 Eli's another
really good friend of mine is uh if it
wasn't for Eli I probably would have no
muscle mass on my body so Eli taught me
how to do that he also works with black
rifle coffee guys and yeah just
all-around good dude you joined the army
because he wanted to be like Solid Snake
I am I've been there yeah never joined
the army but I've had that feeling for
sure it's one of my favorite games ever
um alright this is pretty sweet like you
know we can keep going we could put
lights in the water we could do a lot of
cool stuff but at this point we're at
two and a half hours I gotta take
Gilbert to the vet so I'm gonna keep
working on this during this week I'll
post it you'll see it on my Instagram
follow me @ underscore punisher
underscore on instagram if you want to
see this image taken to the max let's
see join the discord server it's in the
description of this video you guys can
talk about anything cg we can leave any
comments or recommendations on what
tutorials we want to do next and i would
really really really like to release an
asset pack for you guys so that we can
you know we can learn how to maybe we
can learn how to make an asset pack
together but in the meantime if you guys
want to help support me i do have a
website where I have all my photography
from around the world been to Ireland
Japan Shanghai Taiwan Indonesia all
around California a lot of its film
photography and digital photography I
got the store up try to get the prices
as low as I can for you guys the prints
are high-quality archival prints they
never fade they
really really nice yeah I got cool
photos from all around the world so if
you guys are feeling feeling helpful
then this is a good place to go to and
you know we can help support each other
and whatnot so until next time guys
thank you so much don't forget also
there's the playlists for the ambient
ambient Spotify playlist in the
description for this video but yeah um
let's keep going let's make it an
awesome zen garden scene I hope to see
your guys's tag me on Instagram
again that's underscore punisher
underscore and yeah keep learning keep
growing and i'll see you guys next time
peace